these are losing players that if you put
this much in their cup their fault
other people right like you need right
here but I have to know when you are
just about to go and then I take it out
we just empty your cup you can now go
eat a lot more [ __ ]
[Music]
you should really actually be able to
figure this out you need to figure out
who's doing work who bro or the other
Alexa [ __ ] voice part that reminds me
we're going to hire somebody for
Patrick's payments so if you've built
Alexis skills with Google official call
or Google actions or if you're into that
world and know a shitload about it
please hit Patrick up I understand
arbitrage
I understand brand and event and
marketing anything that is leverageable
far beyond when you host the party in
high school you host the party in high
school it's leverage and where'd you
grow up I'd like to be 24 good-looking
and living on the beach me too
I take 24 ugly and living in the sand
living in the block and just time I
would pay for time and anything you do
when you hit that moment yeah and I'm in
that moment on everything that I've been
doing for a decade
I just really understand what to do on
Facebook and Instagram in a way that I'm
at the top of my craft right now yeah I
appreciate it this is not a joke
this is February 2006 YouTube's 5 months
old I'm like if I suggest content I will
end up being on SportsCenter yeah it was
just everything like it's amazing when
you're good add or have like I just
basically knew now the phone wasn't here
yet so what happened was that happened
and that made me jump on Twitter the
second I saw too because I knew that was
connected so in the early days I just
knew that I was gonna and I by the way
you know it's weird I'm only I'm still
kind of weirdly doing it now if you
gobble up all the attention well then
you get to come
United States
I want you to tell me what you want to
do and then I want to see if I can make
it 100% happen you know other pieces
right now you're watching everything
like what things look like what's what's
what what do you want to do today man
thank you that's some people's cups
these are losing players said if you put
this much in their cup their fault
other people right like you need right
here
but I have to know when you're just
about to go and then I take it out we
just come to your cup you can now go eat
a lot more [ __ ] I was making a
demonstration it's really what's up man
we walked Brock what a pleasure
awesome at night wow so many videos is
we run here there's been a lot here
coming to that show the visitation
others though thanks man basically
experience things yeah how's it been
it's great if you are collecting debt
and you're going to college for
marketing for entrepreneurship if you're
bad you're actually pulling off one of
the worst things in the world to do
right now that breaks my heart now if
you're going to be a lawyer if you're
not collecting debt and mom and dad are
taking care of it that's fine I'm not
mad at college like if you want to wear
that got Bane you need to go to an Ivy
League school and get that the great but
if you were going to college to work in
marketing and communications or to be an
entrepreneur and you're collecting debt
because your parents made you or you
think that's the right thing you're
basically pulling off the worst move in
the world
hi here how are you I'm good such a
pleasure
it says - pleasure to meet you how are
things wonderful India ones is all how's
your trip into New York rainy and late
really write it once you get it
Wednesday night 17 from Crown City South
Florida know where you live I live in
Omaha Nebraska that's what I thought
yeah because I love what not some work
in Rapid City area got it very cool
how you doing yeah good
she told me she loves shadow though she
loved it she hey how's it going how's
everything going better talent love it
love the team and we're going to look at
success I think I heard you guys why you
know just yeah yeah listen just like for
videos and that's a real thing is huge
people don't understand there's a
massive difference between sales and
branding yeah and there's so many people
might need to say they're like now what
are you doing and give it all for free
we go why would you do that then they
won't pay you and I have explained over
and over again like you see them you see
the tribe and you get the way for free
doing the right thing always plays out
you know and that's in my philosophy for
years and so when I first heard about
the concept I'm like an all-in I love it
I feel you have zero expectations I
believe the ever yeah so I'm so [ __ ]
happy and I need from like my wife from
like my mom like everything if you can
end up from expectations and does the
future
I just mean ever I just never that's
exact meaning if your expectations you
never of disappointment it's a stew so
long life 100% I'm always pleasantly
surprised I love it well yeah
everything's great then yeah but you
know what it is everything is what it is
you know like what I'm disappointed oh
I'm disappointed because that person
stinks or like but I'm never like but I
don't expect because I'm empathetic
actually think comes from empathy it's
like I'm just like listen she has her
own [ __ ]
of course they work like I also think I
wonder what the mix between I'd love to
get your perspective so I think what
really is driving me is the mix that I'm
extremely empathetic and extremely
talented like and I mean that I know
it's funny to say but I just don't need
anybody's help
like I think when so many knows oh [ __ ]
I need that I need my business partner
to make the money well then it's scary
yeah like I'm never I don't think
anybody is better at anything that I do
um yeah it's just a very good feeling
that confidence in I can you know get
what I need and do what I need to do but
they hear about people 100 percent you
know what else is interesting as we're
talking I also just realized like as
we're building
I also so I fully believe in myself to
get what I can get
I also don't need anything like it'll
get nothing to lose right like like I'm
gonna get everything but like like the
level in which like I just don't kick
like it's just do I want to buy the Jets
I don't want to buy the Jets I want to
try to buy the Jets yeah that's the KPI
yeah well attachments is sort of all
suffering and assuming the intestine
expectation or you attach to a need or
it's like the ultimate freedom for me
it's when you have nothing left to lose
and then everything's a game
[Music]
hardcore day meeting these meetings
meetings meetings meetings meetings
meetings meetings meeting today going
yeah thanks for being here some of you
hey lemon I use LinkedIn Instagram
stories and Facebook like a media site
the team can take content I approve the
content then it goes out as far as
everything else it's all done by my hand
now the team makes the Instagram
creative that I put out on my
maintenance rampage but I approve the
pictures and the words
and then they make them and then I post
them every single comment that you've
ever seen as Gary Vaynerchuk has bidden
by my hands all of them every single
tweet every single everything so every
reply in the comments every time you see
me in YouTube or in my facebook page
like replying that's me I read the
comments on every place because that's
my consumer insights which is why I
think I'm ahead of everybody
people undervalue community management
because they think it's being nice and
giving back to the community it's not
being nice it's the insights to your
next strategy you don't understand the
brain like humans and I think it's
really powerful it's the operating
system of the ultimate species in the
universe right when you start breaking
down kind of interesting right like holy
[ __ ] our brain is the operating system
to the most powerful species in the
universe so my intuition is that the
reason it's so right is because it's
capable of doing it but we don't allow
it to so I will give you a good analogy
I've been working out and getting my
[ __ ] together we even are real like
almost rehab for the last month or two
means you're you might have noticed I've
been like really great I'm holding my
neck you're bringing doesn't allow you
to roll over your worst spot it actually
protects you like like I'm doing my
traps now I did my adductor I'm doing my
neck I can't get there I know I'm trying
to get there like right now as I was
sitting you might as well right I see
some of you noticed I'm trying to get
the spot it won't let me that's so cool
right like I know where it is I'm
literally can't it's really cool right
so you need your trainer to do it that's
why it's like and so I think that's
happening that's the physical
manifestation of what the brains power
is the mental manna station is it knows
what to do we're doing things to stop it
I think I tapped into that and now I
communicate towards it I don't think I'm
even at my crescendo well I'm chipping
I'm chip and I'm chipping maybe in seven
years I'm even communicating better but
a lot of them like [ __ ] is is that what
I'm really good at is just getting to
the [ __ ] punch line right the reason
I am always interrupting people is
[ __ ] I'll just get to the punch line
no and I just you know but I know you do
but I'm empathetic that we haven't
danced for a long time and it's hard to
like fully get how little people how
much people have to say and how little
they have say like I'm 18 minutes late
from 20 minutes away for a family dinner
with my sister and brother who I never
say no but I'm not doing that to I'm
doing that for you really know how it is
I really am I feel like people think I
won't meet with them because I want to
do a selfie with a fan and I'm saying
but you understand right thank you get
me out of here I'm going to go go on a
move with the family rub siblings dinner
my sister my brother my sister Liz a lot
of you don't even know about her that's
our inside family joke have a good
weekend
[Music]